Okay.
Well,
this morning I want in a way to circle
back in time to cover an issue that's
been lurking in the background
but we've never faced directly.
You'll remember that when we talked
about the Paris School of medicine,
there was the ethical issue raised of
the relationship of the patients to the
physicians who are using
them for medical studies.
And we've talked about this as well
in a variety of other contexts.
For example,
in the breakthrough of the mosquito
theory of transmission of malaria,
uh, we've seen that there were
human experiments involved in not,
but there wasn't really an ethical
framework of a formal kind until well into
the 20th century and it's not development
that I want to look at this morning.
The development of a
framework of bioethical, uh,
experimentation for human studies.
And to do that,
I'd like to look at the Tuskegee
syphilis study from 1932 to 1972,
which was if we like the catalyst around
which a framework of biomedical ethics
was developed.
Now the Tuskegee study
was a complex story.
It captured the national imagination
because it seemed to embody everybody's
fears as a worst case
scenario in medical ethics.
Tuskegee as a study embodied a number
of features that contributed to that.
Clearly it demonstrates as I think
we'll see the corrupting influence of
commercial considerations on
medicine and medical research.
It demonstrates the negative
impacts of scientific arrogance.
It brings out the dangers of
a military chain of command,
model of public health in which no one
questions or resists decisions from
higher authority.
It shows the exploitation of the poor
and disadvantaged by powerful interests
and the government.
And it also clearly embodies racism.
This is an experiment that began with
an idea that racial groups are serious
biological category,
not just a social one,
but that races are biological entities.
And that the differences from one group
to another are so significant that
diseases themselves follow different
paths in the bodies of different racial
groups.
Well,
the place where this unfolded was um,
in Macon County,
Alabama in the 1930s
and Tuskegee is here,
um,
in Alabama.
Let me look a little more closely.
Uh,
that's Macon County in
the state of Alabama.
Now, there are a number of features
we need to think about when we're,
remember Nate Macon County and we need
to take off our 21st century spectacles
and think back to different world.
In the 1930s when this
experiment got underway,
and at that time Macon County was one
of the most disadvantaged places in the
whole of the United States.
It had a large population of poor and
illiterate African American sharecroppers,
and this was the time of
apartheid in our country.
Studies had revealed in connection
with the social conditions of the
sharecroppers in Macon County,
an overwhelming burden
of disease and suffering
in a rigidly segregated environment.
The African American population
was also overwhelmingly illiterate.
In fact,
the state of Alabama spent $65 a year
on each white student in the county,
but less than $7 for every
African American student.
Venereal diseases and especially syphilis,
were also rampant in Macon County.
Well,
the story that unfolds
is a pretty awful one,
but paradoxically it begins
with good intentions.
The good intentions were those of a
philanthropic program established by an
organization,
I guess we would call it an NGO.
The Julius Rosenwald Fund was involved
at the time was the president of the
Sears and Roebuck company
and under these auspices,
Dr. Thomas Paren conducted a study of
syphilis in the south in 1929 and 30 and
this study had a clear moral purpose.
The idea was that it was to begin by
demonstrating the burden of syphilis and
that this would be a first step that
would pave the way for the federal
government subsequently to step in and
establish a national syphilis eradication
program.
The vision was this,
in year one there would be a Bosserman
test survey of six states in the south of
this country that is
establishing the extent,
the prevalence of syphilis and the
second year they would begin a program of
treatment and of education.
Let's look at what was found
in the beginning of the
study year one was actually
completed and it found that the United
States how to national rate for syphilis
of four per every thousand of population.
Yeah.
On the other hand,
for African Americans,
the rate was 7.2
for every thousand of population work
syphilitic but if we come now to Macon
County,
Alabama,
and that's the point that statistics
were absolutely staggering,
fully 360 and no,
I'm not making a mistake.
360 per thousand of population of the
African American population of Macon
County, Alabama was found to
be afflicted with syphilis.
So Macon County,
and this is the point,
was clearly placed on the map as the
very ideal place if you're interested in
how syphilis affected the bodies of
African Americans in particular African
American males.
Well,
the year two of this fill the
philanthropic program never got under way.
The reason was simple.
It was the Great Depression and
funding for the program vanished.
The phase that had been
intended of education,
of treatment and hopefully of
eradication never materialized.
What remained was only the initial study
at this point in the wake of the
activity of the Rosenwald Fund,
the United States public health service
intervened and it had as we'll see,
two very different objectives.
The first was associated with this men
and the idea of the
syphilis study was hit.
He was his brainchild.
This is tall lover Clark.
And his idea was to have,
um,
a scientific and racial curiosity.
There had been at the turn of the century,
a Scandinavian study on the course of
untreated syphilis in the human body that
was conducted in Scandinavia.
And Dr. Clark thought that
since the earlier study had
involved a Nordic people,
it would be really intriguing,
really neat to do a companion study to
show the natural history of syphilis
untreated in the body of
the African American male.
And if you wanted to do that
kind of study in this country,
what place could possibly be better than
making county which offered unlimited
material for just such observations.
And Clark started with a profoundly
racist to PA phasis that he wished to
demonstrate and not as the simple one
that the African American male was
racially distinct from the white
male and was so in ways that could be
demonstrated by studying the natural
history of syphilis in their bodies.
It was thought,
or at least he thought that African
American men had such a high incidence of
syphilis because of their irresistible
fewer sex Wallace and they're deficient
cranio capacity,
but didn't really leave enough
room for gray mater to control it.
Secondly,
once established in the body of
the African American men syphilis,
Dr. Clark believed ran a different course
than it would in the body of the white
men and he had an idea of what
he expected that difference to be
and the bonding of white males.
The damage was overwhelmingly to,
they're more highly evolved
and therefore more vulnerable
neurological systems.
Okay.
You inspect expected that the result
in African American males would be very
different,
being less neurologically sophisticated.
Their bodies would experience damage
instead primarily to their cardiovascular
systems
and proof was to be gained by studying
the natural course of the disease and a
group of males,
African American males who
were systematically untreated.
So let's keep this in mind,
it's to be on the bodies of African males
that are systematically not treated.
So let's remember that this is a
study that was based not on any fear
therapeutic objective.
On the contrary,
the main interest of the syphilis study
conducted at Tuskegee was to examine
syphilitic black male bodies post mortem
for this reason as the biomedical
ethicist Susan letterer explains,
the real purpose of this study was
not to treat the African American men
involved as subjects or even as bodies.
Okay.
But rather as cadavers
that had not yet died.
Let me quote the words of one of the
physicians involved in the study who wrote
the following,
the most important phase of the study,
which to follow as many patients as
possible to post mortem examination.
Okay.
In order to determine the prevalence
and severity of the syphilitic disease
process.
Yeah.
One physician of the US public health
service express the thought very
succinctly and with chilling candor,
he said once the study was established,
the subjects had no more interest
for us and killed. They were dead.
Okay,
well,
what's the second objective of this study?
The second aim of the study was
often as often not remembered.
So clearly it was more commercially
driven and less well known.
Remember,
cast your mind back to the 1930s
okay.
And worldwide at that time there was
a vast and stable demand for reliable
diagnostic
for syphilis.
The demand was created first of
all by law laws that required,
for example,
testing for syphilis before marriage
testing for syphilis before induction into
the army.
And still at this time at the start
of the 1930s there was no absolutely
reliable diagnostic test for the disease.
Furthermore,
developing such a test was scientifically
challenging because of a feature of
Treponema pallidum the closet,
this spire Keat that as you know,
that's the pathogen
responsible for syphilis.
The treponema Pallidum as one of
its features has extreme fragility.
It could not really be cultivated
in the laboratory at this time.
So there was an alternative
the experimenters thought,
and that was a simple one to keep a
ready supply of serum available through
regular blood samples from
untreated syphilis subjects.
I started to say patients,
but the point is they aren't patients.
They weren't to be treated.
They were subjects
and indeed in the course
of the SIF Tuskegee study
itself to new reliable tests
were developed using Tuskegee blood
and they were successfully marketed
these two tests where the venereal disease
research laboratory test was one and
the other was called the fluorescent
Trepan Nimol antibody absorption test.
And needless to say,
the subjects of this experiment,
we're never paid for this particular
service that they rendered to science.
Well,
a problem faced taller for
Clark and his experimenters.
The problem was to recruit volunteers,
volunteers to take part in a study
that had no therapeutic purpose.
Why would you volunteer?
You might ask to take part in a
study that has no benefit for you,
but whose purpose in fact
was to use your living body as a natural
history exhibit to observe pathology
while the subjects received no treatment.
And while their blood serum,
which used as a culture medium,
well,
they thought of a solution and that was
to make use of the ample availability of
African American males in Macon County
who were vulnerable to manipulation
because they were desperately poor because
they were illiterate.
Because they had almost no
access to medical care and
the medical profession and
because at this very moment they had
a substantial and as yet unfulfilled
expectation,
the expectation created unknowingly by
the Roosevelt involved study that there
would soon be a therapeutic intervention
of the United States government.
So what the United States Public
Health Service did was to send out mass
postings to block churches in Macon County
and these letters and placards let it
be known that the government was on
barking on the long
awaited treatment program.
Let me be clear again about that.
The announcement by the
public health service was not,
the second phase was underway and
that what was coming was a program of
treatment
treatment for anyone who thought
that he or she will. In this case,
he had what was called bad blood.
Now bad blood in Macon County,
Alabama was not a scientific term,
but a really elastic term,
local term borrowed from popular culture
that had a number of inconsistent
meanings.
Bad blood might mean anemia.
It might mean simple indigestion.
It might mean venereal disease.
So if you had bad blood,
whatever that was,
treatment is on the way.
And in addition to treatment volunteers,
if you volunteered were promised that in
due course they would be provided with
all funeral expenses.
Courtesy of the u s government provided
they allow their bodies to be subjected
to autopsy.
The famous postmortem examination
that tall over was so enthusiastic
about,
they would also be provided with free
meals occasionally and free transport to
the treatment center.
So what was on offer might not seem
enormously expensive and I think it's a
reflection of their dramatic conditions,
social conditions of people at the
time that large numbers of people came
forward
and approximately 600 were selected and
they were regarded by those who were
rejected as the fortunate ones.
They were lucky they'd been taken
into a treatment program of the u s
government.
And after selection,
the 600 were divided into two groups.
399 were found to have syphilis and
they formed this study group 200 without
syphilis served as controls.
Now this raises,
um,
an ethical issue immediately
were these volunteers.
I would argue that these 600 African
American males can only by some stretch of
the imagination be called volunteers
for a really simple reason.
You can't be a volunteer if you're
lied to about that for which you're
volunteering.
In other words,
they volunteered for one thing and what
was put in place was something radically
different.
They were promised treatment,
but treatment was precisely what they
were to be denied systematically for the
remainder of their lives.
Let me quote tall over Clark who presided
over the first year of the study and
directly approved the
use of this deception.
He wrote this to a colleague.
These negros are very,
very ignorant and easily influenced by
things that would be a minor significance
to a more intelligent group.
Now,
what was the site of this study?
Um,
this is a picture of one of the buildings
of Tuskegee institute now known as
Tuskegee University.
It had a very honorable history.
It was founded by booker t Washington
for the education of freed men after the
civil war.
And it wasn't used to cooperate by the
idea that such cooperation with the study
would enhance its prestige.
And would gain access for
it to government funding.
And there was an African American nurse.
We see her here, uh, with uh, Doctor,
uh,
Yunus rivers who was the local African
American nurse who served as the
intermediary between the physicians
of the Public Health Service and the
subjects of the experiment. No
Lot's been written about, um,
nurse rivers and her
role and the experiment.
I think that we ought to remember the
context of the time and the training in
which nurses were trained not to
question but to do as they were told.
Now at the outset,
something also paradoxical happen
and I would argue that in fact,
even if you wanted to have an entirely
cold blooded look at scientific validity
for section study,
this particular study was made
scientifically invalid from the outset.
At the beginning,
the experimenters ruined any possibility
that the study could ever produce
violet scientific results because the
government doctors began the study by
administering a small dose of
the accepted therapy of the day.
In other words,
the experiment is to begin to have an
study of untreated syphilis and they begin
by administering a small dose of the
established therapeutic revocation of the
day, which is a combination
of awkward arsenic and mercy,
funny mercury compounds plus Bismuth.
So this ruined the premise of observing
purely untreated syphilis sticks.
Then further weakening the scientific,
if we call it that validity of this study,
was the fact that some members of the
control group contracted venereal disease
and they were simply
transferred to the test group.
So they shuffled the deck between
the study group and a control group.
Well thereafter.
Nonetheless,
this particular study continued for 40
years down until 1972 and the volunteers
thereafter received no further treatment.
They were subject to
regular annual physical
and blood tests and do spinal taps and
they were given something that they
thought was medicine.
It was called pink medicine
and they took it regularly.
And actually what it was is aspirin.
Let me give you a primary source.
This is the Macon County health department
and this is the notice that was given
to those who were experimenting.
It says, dear. So sir,
sometime ago you were given a thorough
examination and since that time we hope
you've gotten a great deal of treatment.
Notice the word treatment for bad blood.
You will now be given your last
chance to get a second examination.
This examination is a very special
one and after it is finished,
you will be given a special treatment.
I underline that word.
If it is believed you are
in a condition to stand it.
And let me just look at the very bottom
in case you missed anything along the
way. At the bottom you could read,
remember this is your last chance
for special free treatment.
Be sure to meet the nurse.
So the deception in this study
was systematic and extended.
In fact,
there was a time when there was a great
threat to this Tuskegee study and that
was when America entered the Second World
War because at that time there was the
danger that the members of the study
group risk to being drafted into the army
and that would entail blood tests,
their syphilis would be discovered and
the army would provide treatment ending
the experiment.
So the assistant surgeon general of the
United States intervened on behalf of
the study and provided the
selective service board of
Macon county with the list
of all those men included in the study
and they were exempted from the military
draft?
No.
At the outset of this experiment,
what was the therapy for syphilis?
What is the treatment that these
men were being deprived of?
And we have to say that
by contemporary standards,
the treatment at the time
was not highly effective.
Okay.
And the most that we can say is it,
the members of the study at the outset
were being denied the best available care
of the standards of the time.
This was the metal metal
therapy as it was called.
Then I mentioned before.
Okay.
But what about later on?
This study continues from 32 to 72
I later in the 1940s penicillin,
a highly efficacious remedy
for syphilis was developed.
Okay.
And it was determined that the members
of the study would be systematically
denied the antibiotic as well.
Local doctors in Macon County.
We're all provided with the names of
the members of the study and they were
instructed by the public health service
that those men were not to be given
penicillin.
So the study continued for 25 more
years when a therapy actually existed.
Well by 1972 at the conclusion,
28 of the men in the study
died directly from syphilis.
100 others died of complications
related to syphilis.
40 wives of members of the study were
infected with syphilis and 19 children
fathered by members of the study
were born with congenital syphilis.
There was however no intention and the
public health service to terminate the
study
and this was not strictly
speaking a secret study.
There were published
reports on a regular basis.
This is really one of the more
disconcerting parts of this study.
What does it say about
our society at the time?
Okay,
the first report,
there's another words.
This is a study and the kind of study
that was published that was written about
publicly and scholarly articles
and people thought this was okay.
The first published report was in 1936
and papers were late or written every
four to six years or so until 1970
and strikingly there was never a within
the medical community about reports on
this type of study that appeared
in medical journals for 40 years.
In 1969 a committee of the Center for
Disease Control Determined that the study
should continue
and this conclusion was backed by
local chapters of the American Medical
Association.
Yeah,
the end came only in 1972 when a former
employee of the public health service
named Peter Buxton reported this
story to the Associated Press.
An article appeared in the
Washington Star in July,
1972 and this caused a national scandal
with charges against the government of
hiring carried out your moral
equivalent of Nazi medicine,
of abuse, of state power, of racism,
and many other things.
A famous book appeared by
James Jones called bad blood,
bad blood.
You now know what that means.
There was a play Ms. Rivers,
boys by David felt shoe.
There was a movie Miss Evers boys in 1997
the attorney Fred Gray initiated a lawsuit
on behalf of the patients and there
was an out of court settlement that gave
surviving patients medical treatment at
last,
at last and $40,000 in compensation.
So let's think about the
ethics of this experiment.
What was learned and what ethical
framework was established to prevent a
recurrence of something of the kind
we need to remember in judging the ethics
of those who initiated and continued
the study there.
At the time it started,
there were no clearly
spelled out guidelines for
biomedical research on Human
Beings,
and it would be unfair and anachronistic
to hold researchers retrospectively
accountable for the standards of 2010
but I think we need to look at the
concerns that were raised by medical
ethicists and a variety of forms with
regard to this experiment.
Remembering.
Of course some of the
considerations were retrospective,
but I'm going to argue that many ethical
base bases made this unethical even by
the standards of 1932 well
places where this were raised.
There was a congressional investigation
led by Senator Edward Kennedy that took
place in 1973
the national medical association
produced a report in the same year.
There was a national research act in
1974 that created what was called the
national commission for the protection
of human subjects of biomedical and
Behavioral Research,
which came to be known
popularly as the Belmont report.
There was the class action suit on behalf
of the survivors and their relatives
that I mentioned,
and in 1997 there was an official
presidential apology by President Bill
Clinton,
of which more in just a minute,
the standard that the medical ethicists
applied was Emmanuel constant notion of
a categorical imperative,
and that is that ethical problems.
And here I over simplifying
cons definitely,
but the general idea,
which is what is important to us and
the context of the conclusions of the
Belmont report was an ethical problems
arise whenever a human being is not used
as an end for his or her own benefit.
Yeah,
but it's used only as the means
to some further ulterior objective
under round to give teeth and
specific content to that idea.
A number of corollaries,
we're said to flow Tim
gang thought meaningful.
The first was,
and we live with this and
you will know the phrase,
the doctrine of informed consent.
Now remember the letter to the
volunteers that I showed you sang.
Remember this is your last
chance for free treatment.
Be sure to meet the nurse that
was hardly informed consent.
We know about the hooks
of the pink medicine,
the ethically up to this
use of that term bad blood,
which wasn't a medically valid concept.
The fact that the volunteers
were never informed of the and
utility of penicillin and you can't
really have informed consent if you don't
know what you're consenting to.
The subjects were never specifically
told that they had syphilis about the
course of the disease.
There were never consulted about what
possible treatment options were available
and spinal taps were presented to
them as what were called spinal shots.
Once again,
a sly and deceptive play on words,
which suggested that the spinal
taps had some therapeutic purpose.
Isn't that what you understand when you
go to the doctors and you got a shot?
The second thing that was thought to be
an ethical response that's necessary and
biomedical research is the idea.
The principle of beneficence.
That is the subjects of a scientific and
medical experiment should be entitled
to the expectation that some benefit
will ensue for their suffering and their
participation.
And the point about this study in Tuskegee
was that it was entirely designed to
be non-therapeutic.
There would never be a benefit
to those who took part.
A third major principle outlined is not
biomedical research should be governed
by what was called justice.
And by that was meant the principle
that the most vulnerable members of his
society should not be chosen
as experimental subjects
to the maximum extent
possible.
In other words,
biomedical research
should refrain from doing.
It's experiments on prisoners on
the mentally deficient on children,
the poor,
and members of disadvantaged minorities,
people who can be easily misled,
coerced,
or intimidated.
And the point about this experiment
was that the subject should Tuskegee.
We're targeted precisely because
they were maximally vulnerable.
A fourth notion that should
govern biomedical research
is not of a well designed
experiment.
Now,
you asked how come not becomes an ethical
category than an experiment should be?
Well designed.
The protocols should be so drafted
that the anticipated results have a
reasonable chance of resulting from
the procedures adopted another words,
if you take part in a
biomedical experiment,
there should be the expectation that the
experiment is so designed that any risk
that you take such as it is,
should not be entirely in vain.
So,
and ethical principle that was sad was
violated when the Tuskegee experiment
began with a dose of therapy and then
began by mixing the test and control
groups.
So whatever suffering was undergone by
the subjects or the experiment would
never have any scientific standing.
In other words,
they're suffering would be
entirely without benefit to anyone.
A fifth thing,
it's not a ethical experiment should
not violate the law and the existing
ethical guidelines of the
government professional and
international authorities.
Well,
this study in Alabama
violated the law of ninth,
sorry,
uh,
the law of 1927 which mandated
treatment for syphilis.
There was also during the
course of the experiment.
Let's get rid of that.
There we go. Ah, we won't
hear that again. Uh, the, uh,
there was also the idea in 1946,
there was an American Medical Association
Judiciary Council that an issue the
report establishing the
principle of voluntary consent.
In other words,
ethical standards emerge during the course
of the experiment that weren't there
at the outset.
But the experiment continued to violate
ethical standards that were established
after it began.
And in 1964,
the World Health Organization issued a
health Sankey declaration that said that
informed consent should lie at
the basis of biomedical research.
Two other things,
ah,
were mentioned as
ethically very important.
One was not in future.
The assessment of the ethics of medical
research should not be by a closed
medical cast.
In other words,
doctors shouldn't establish themselves
that what they're doing is ethical.
There should be independent review
boards to establish that and then this
experiment which said to violate also
the civil rights enshrined the American
Constitution,
the 13th amendment against involuntary
servitude and the 14th amendment against
trespass.
Yeah.
Now the question is do any of those,
what can we say about those who embarked
in 1932 they didn't have the framework
of the Belmont report.
The Helsinki Declaration did Judicial
Council report of the American Medical
Association,
but I would argue
but a judgment on this
isn't all retrospective.
I'd remind you that already at the
start of the experiment in 1932 it was
unethical for physicians to lie to their
patients and research subjects and that
it was unethical for a research program
to violate the law of Alabama of 1927
that mandated treatment for
anyone known to have syphilis.
Well, what's the legacy of
the Tuskegee experiment?
Well, they're positive and
negatives on the positive side.
This established a legally binding
ethical framework for biomedical research.
The universe of conducting biomedical
research is now entirely different from
that in 1932 and that's an
entirely a positive gain.
This study Dan did produce
something really positive,
which is an ethical framework.
There's also the fact,
and this is positive too,
there was a wide debate of all of
these issues through the press,
through plays, congressional
debates, scholarly literature,
television broadcasts,
President Clinton's public apology and
the coverage it received and all of you
are well know that phrase
about informed consent
on the negative side,
there were the sufferings of
this study members, their wives,
their children born with
congenital syphilis. There was,
I'm don to a great university,
Tuskegee University and its reputation.
There was harm done in terms
of a breakdown in trust
between African Americans
on the one hand and the medical profession
and the government on the other.
And when can see the legacy of this in
the HIV AIDS pandemic that we're coming
to in 19
when asked if HIV AIDS as an
epidemic was a genocidal plot,
an opinion poll of African
Americans revealed the 10%
responded yes and 20% that
they were not sure.
So at that time,
in the 1990s 30% of African Americans
thought that perhaps HIV AIDS was not a
disease,
but a genocidal plot.
And this had consequences,
consequences in terms of the failure of
people to seek medical and public health
education and treatment.
If your level of distrust
is pitched. Dot. Hi,
you can understand that.
And one of the reasons was
the Tuskegee experiment.
So then I'd like to close by remembering
Clinton's apology and the White House.
And May 16th,
1997 there were,
at that time a experiments,
survivors,
including this man,
Howard Shaw,
plus representatives of three others.
And I'm can't compete with
Bill Clinton and eloquence.
So I'd rather simply end by quoting him.
What he said was the United States
government did something that was wrong,
deeply, profoundly, morally wrong.
It was an outrage to our commitment
to integrity and equality for all our
citizens,
to the survivors,
to the wives and family members,
the children and grandchildren.
I say what you know,
no power on earth can give
you back the lives lost.
The pain suffered,
the years of internal torment and anguish.
What was done cannot be undone,
but we can end the silence.
We can stop turning our heads away.
We can look at you in the eye and finally
say on behalf of the American people.
What the United States
government did was shameful,
and I am sorry
that people who ran the study at
Tuskegee diminished the stature of men by
abandoning the most
basic ethical precepts.
They forgot their pledge
to heal and repair.
They had the power to heal.
They're survivors and all the others,
but they did not.
Today.
All we can do is apologize,
but you have the power for only you.
That is Mr. Shaw and
the others who are here.
The family members who are with us in
Tuskegee only you have the power to
forgive your presence shows that you've
chosen a better path than our government
did so long ago.
You have not withheld
the power to forgive.
I hope today and tomorrow
that every American will
remember this lesson and live
by it.